well it was a just and sadly necessary  war and we have to find the ways of  remembering that together though of  course a hundred years on we have to  remember it together in a way that helps  international relations for the future  that promotes better understanding for  the future but there's no doubt when you  look at the at the history that Britain  had to act in the way that it did in  order to preserve international security  and peace and democracy and so while we  should be proud of that we should  conduct ourselves in these  commemorations that begin this year in a  way that promotes future understanding  and peace between nations and I think we  can strike that balance